what's going on guys we're doing another
day in the life of video here now with
the all-new zv1f which was just
announced of course this is the baby
brother to the zv1 which was released a
couple years ago very small compact uh
camera designed for creators content
creators it's primarily video focus of
course it does take photos it is a one
inch sensor this is a 20.1 megapixel one
inch sensor versus the zv1 which is 21
megapixel so you get the same one
megapixel will make a difference
probably not anyway uh this is a
contrast based autofocusing system which
is very Odyssey from Sony because we
have not seen this in many many years so
how does it perform we're going to find
out we're going to a dog adoption center
I'm going to check this out on behalf of
Volkswagen Singapore here's my baby girl
prob behind me right there who's going
to go with me and we're going to test it
with animal tracking people tracking
we're testing it uh just in terms of
video quality so you be the judge to see
how this camera performs so with that
let's go over to the dog adoption center
at Volkswagen Singapore
Pride look look what are you doing what
are you doing
what are you doing quick stop light
check here so far so good I have to say
colors are nice out of the camera
4K 25p can't complain
all right here we go in
it's gonna be a little bit tricky here
with
the dog
and trying to review a camera oh man
this is going to be tough
hey how are you Racine
excited
so that is a dog that dog's tired the
dog's tired
yeah
tired huh no you can't have the food so
far this is quite easy to use I have to
say contrast based Auto focusing is not
bad from Sony perhaps Panasonic can take
a lesson or two just saying
foreign
by the way can we just take a moment to
appreciate the new rtn R line look at
this thing look how beautiful this car
is
I love the gray on that this gray is
awesome
this is really really nice
this is stunning
I love good cars I love good looking
cars let's take a quick walk around here
at the Volkswagen showroom take a look
at some cars
doing to go see the torreg now the tour
egg is probably my favorite of all the
of the SUVs because it's just massive
and it's beautiful and it's so nice to
drive now
here a little more refined of a color
and go inside look at this interior how
awesome this is this interior is
beautiful absolutely amazing yeah this
is a fantastic SUV I mean the tiguanism
as well I mean I've actually love my
tbr1 for the past year it's been
phenomenal but the r10 the r10 is
gorgeous anyway that's it for cars and
here's a message from our sponsor this
video is brought to you by Asus check
out the Asus Zenbook 14x OLED Space
Edition commemorating the 25th
anniversary of the first Asus laptop
sent into space Not only does it offer a
space exclusive design but it's even
worthy of going where no man has gone
before with its base grade durability it
even comes with a 3.5 inch OLED
companion Zen Vision display and you
will have a ball of a time taking
interviews with a 16 by 10 4K OLED Nano
Edge Pantone validated 14 inch display I
mean the zb1f is a nice camera the
contrast based system it's a little bit
slower than the phasey tech but it's
locking on the eye tracking is here it's
not as precise of course as the zv1 and
I'm kind of perplexed why Sony decided
to use a contrast based system at what
point you go look just basically tucked
all the way that's what Sony cameras are
known for is the auto focusing
I don't know don't make the decision
anyway overall battery life on this
thing it does drain relatively fast
you're gonna need multiple batteries if
you want to get this camera the same as
the zv1 the controllers on the back are
very small to use I wouldn't say it's
the most user-friendly camera out there
it is what it is I mean it's a standard
focal length 20 millimeters F2 which is
good for vlogging I'm on active
stabilization so there's a little bit of
a crop in but I'm holding it here with
the Sony hand grip and it's pretty
decent here for vlogging and that's what
this camera is really meant for but now
that we're using portrait mode for a lot
of our videos for tick tock and for
reals does it make sense with this
camera outside of YouTube which I'm
shooting right now I don't know we're
meant to be seen but yeah that's a zv1f
in a nutshell I'm not sure about this
camera I'm really not I am a little bit
perplexed
do we need the zb1f is it necessary
does our smartphone do the same thing
I mean I get that the lens obviously the
20 millimeter F2 lens so you're gonna
probably get a better depth of field and
obviously it'll probably take better
photos but
does it
sense nowadays
a day this is the question I have that I
think a lot of you are going to have
with the zv1f the zv1 okay the zve E10
made a lot of sense to me because that
is an interchangeable aps-c camera small
compact grade for Content creators you
can get some really good image quality
out of that
this
not too sure battery life it's almost
down right now and I'm literally like
need to switch batteries and I've only
been using it for
a couple hours you know off and on not
even full on
yeah
seems a bit it's a question I think a
lot of us are going to have with this
camera
I don't think I can answer it in this
review
foreign